je ne connais pas personnellement ce
document par contre ce que je peux vous
affirmer je voulais approche lorsque
l'on regarde ailleurs mais ça m'étonne
que vous ne le connaissez je ne le
connais pas personnellement
[Musique]
alors je voulais vous montrer des images
qui date d'octobre 2018 elles sont ici
on va aller regarder ensemble
vous reconnaissez c'était place de la
république à paris ses livres des livres
ou manifester à l'époque contre une
baisse des tarifs
est ce qu'on a le droit tout simplement
de manifester quand on est livreur des
libéraux
tout le monde en france le droit de
manifester jeudi
quand on a eu accès à des échanges de
mails en interne ou en fait mail interne
entre responsables de délits verrou ses
mails montre que vous avez utilisé votre
système de géolocalisation pour
identifier les manifestants alors je
vais vous montrer le premier voilà il
est ici je vous le confie comme ça vous
pouvez regarder le jeu play après je
pense avoir identifié une grande partie
des grévistes
grâce à home monitoring rider
l'occassion qui est donc votre système
de géolocalisation et dans ce mail le
responsable qui écrit mentionne les
dates voyez c'est ici des 12 19 et 21
octobre qui sont bien les dates de
manifestations date
des manifestations dont on voudrait
montrer des images donc ce système de
géolocalisation vous a bien permis
d'identifier des grévistes c'est ce
qu'écrit un responsable de shell de
l'hiver ou dans un échange de mails
alors sur ce cas précis c'est pas
exactement je découvre ce document avec
vous donc je ne suis pas en mesure de
commenter ou je pense que vous
comprendrez amis ça c'est par contre ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que nous
n'identifions pas les grévistes a
délivré ses fessiers le contraire qui
est écrit sur ce dernier point sur ce
point pour vous préciser avoir identifié
une grande partie des grévistes grâce au
monitoring rider l'occassion c'est écrit
par un nouveau responsable
et là pour le coup c'est extrêmement est
simple il n'y a pas d'identification des
grévistes en france
la preuve que si nous n'identifions pas
des grévistes en france
si c'est avéré nous condamnerons bien
entendu cette pratique est d'accord
alors on va même aller plus loin parce
que le même responsable demande dans un
autre document et là vous allez voir que
c'est assez clair de constituer des
dossiers contre les manifestants alors
regardez ce document vous allez le voir
avec moi
merci beaucoup je pense qu'on tient nos
leaders c'est ce qui est écrit ici au
tout début
peux-tu checker pour tous et non
commande jamais livré donc volé et plus
loin tout ce que tu peux trouver et qui
ne les arrange pas cercle non seulement
vous les repérer grâce à la
géolocalisation
mais ça va plus loin que ça ça que vous
tentez de monter un dossier contre
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on croit
comprendre dans ce mail clairement moi
ce que je encore une fois je découvre ce
document vous le présenter devant moi
vous comprendrez que je le découvre et
donc je n'ai pas le contexte que je ne
le souhaite pas le commenter
plus que ça d'accord est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est normal d'établir des
listes et ensuite de faire une liste
noire parce que c'est ça c'est une liste
noire des grévistes qu'est ce que vous
en pensez c'est grave quand même pour
une entreprise
donc je vous demande juste votre
réaction je voulais dit sur le document
mais je ne répèterai sur ce document là
c'est des documents dont je n'ai pas
connaissance et que je découvre devant
c'est pas je veux dire c'est des
managers de délivrer ou qu'ils échangent
ça entre donc je suis très étonné que
vous ne soyez pas au courant mais je
pourrais dire je découvre ce document
trentemoult il a fait plus d'une demi
heure oui oui il ya un autre rendez vous
ouais d'accord ou non tiendrai au
courant oui simple et ça me plaît et
vous demander ce qui s'est passé ensuite
parce que c'est important quand même
tout à fait ok merci sociologues
devraient s'ouvrir donc aucun problème
là dessus merci beaucoup monsieur
loupiots place est un très gentil mais
en vain
[Musique]